ever since man first appeared on this earth
he has had to struggle for existence he is
there to fight wild animals famine and sickness
besides having had to be on guard against his
fellow man nature's dangers were always held in
check because he man had the power of reason and
with that reason he overcame fear but when it
came to defending himself against other men who
were envious of what he possessed the task of
defending himself became more complex because
his attackers had invented weapons at first
he feared these weapons because he couldn't
immediately understand them but as soon as he
overcame fear he used his power of reason to
fashion defenses against them he made shields to
ward off Spears then he in turn invented better
weapons in order to protect himself and down
through history the story repeated itself over and
over as arms became more powerful the defense's
surpassed them in strength but this happened only
after fear was overcome today the importance of
overcoming fear is far greater than it has ever
been and this can only be done by familiarizing
ourselves with the effects of the atomic bomb
the only newspaperman who was assigned to
officially cover the entire atomic project is
mr. William L Lawrence science writer for the New
York Times and twice a few litter Prize winner he
is also the author of dawn over zero the dramatic
firsthand report of the birth of the atomic
bomb and hell bombs the account of an even more
powerful weapon therefore mr. Lawrence is one of
the persons most qualified to give us his views
for an approach to a method of defense against
atomic warfare I saw with my own eyes its power
of the exploding atom I witness the end of an
era and the beginning of a new one I saw a world
blow up in a burst of cosmic fire and a new one
born from its ashes I saw a great city disappear
in a mushroom cloud in a fraction of a millionth
of a second right then I knew that here at last
ma'am had a weapon that could destroy civilization
the atomic bomb is the most powerful physical
destructive weapon history has ever known but
it is above all a psychological terror weapon does
this mean that we are helpless against an atomic
attack most certainly not there is definitely
a defense against the atomic bomb provided we
faithfully carry out a plan method of defense
notes very carefully what is to power for what
you are about to see and here is your pattern
for survival thank you Bill Lawrence in order to
properly defend ourselves against an atomic attack
we've got to learn and remember what happens when
such a bomb explodes so let's examine the simple
scientific facts about the atomic bomb as an atom
of uranium 235 is forced to split it releases a
fantastic amount of energy causing the explosion
this reaction is known as nuclear fission as the
atoms explode they create destruction three ways
first the shockwave the force of the explosion
pushes the air around and from the centre at great
speeds this pressure makes buildings crumble the
effects of the shock wave will be felt for several
seconds similar to an explosion of many thousands
of tons of TNT second the bomb discharges the heat
wave which at its source as many times hotter
than the Sun this is known as the heat flash
this flash of intense heat lasts only a few
seconds but it's intense light can start fires
as far away as to and can inflict serious flash
burns unless the skin is protected third the bomb
radiates a tremendous amount of gamma rays these
are similar to x-ray when an air blast occurs the
gamma rays are dissipated within a fraction of
a second and do not extend beyond a mile but if
the bomb explodes on the ground it leaves what is
known as residual radiation in other words highly
radioactive fragments of the bomb are embedded in
the ground now that we know roughly how the bomb
works we will see what kind of damage it can
do and how we can protect ourselves according
to the information released by our scientists
we know that the bomb is most destructive when
exploded about 2,000 feet above the ground the
point directly under the blast is called ground
zero all distances are measured from this point in
the area within 1/2 mile from Ground Zero there is
virtually total destruction in order for a person
to survive within this area he must be protected
by a shelter which can withstand the shockwave
the heat flash and the gamma rays this type of
shelter must be located underground and must have
walls and ceiling of reinforced concrete the area
beginning at 1/2 mile from Ground Zero to one mile
from it will be seriously damaged but chances for
survival in this area are good if there has been
enough time after the alert to reach the shelters
all those who cannot reach the shelters many will
survive by crouching flat against the main pillars
in the basements of heavy concrete buildings
beyond one mile from Ground Zero even many
who won't have time to reach the shelters will
have a good chance to live if they react quickly
at this point you're going to ask what chance
does that leave us can anything be done about it
yes definitely and here it is we've simplified
it for you all the way first let's begin with
the home if your home has a cellar you can easily
and economically convert it into an ideal shelter
by building an outside entrance to it and by
reinforcing the ceiling with heavy beams finally
if you haven't the means to do any building then
convert the room in your house with the least
number of windows preferably with no windows at
all since the shockwave can shatter windows as far
as 10 miles away flying splinters of glass claws
a very large percentage of injuries so prepare a
barricade then put a strong support on top so low
that the flying glass and falling debris won't
hurt you these sandbags will also protect you
from the heat flash and radiation to give your
home some protection against fire the color of
the paint should be as light as possible because
light-colored surfaces reflect heat for as dark
colors absorb it the roof shingles should be of a
fireproof material those of us who work in offices
or stars must familiarize ourselves with the exact
location of the nearest shelters as a safety
precaution against a surprise attack pick out the
strongest and most sheltering piece of furniture
or fixture under which you can crawl remember the
glass splinters and the falling debris for this
is one of the deadliest things in your house glass
now whether your shoulder is in the basement of
your office or at your home prepared kit similar
to this one and have it handy at all times for
any eventualities include enough bottled water
to last you for several days raisins chocolate
canned food and chlorine tablets for your drinking
water a small burner a skillet tableware and
the large box of matches a first-aid kit that
includes sterile bandages iodine vaseline
jelly and sunburn cream not lotion a good
supply of grease cutting soap some blankets extra
clothing and a pair of heavy gloves a flashlight
with spare batteries and some candles a Red Cross
first-aid handbook a handbook on defense against
atomic warfare on map of your city and one of
your neighboring copies and photostatic copies
of your identification papers a portable radio
with spare batteries well those are the material
preparations but what should you personally do
how should you act it's unlikely of course that
an enemy will completely surprise us but even
with warning will you act sensibly without panic
attention attention both of you in your homes
shut off the gas and electricity drop all the
curtains and close the venetian blinds if
you have them this precaution will reduce
injuries from broken glass run to your
shelters do not go outside but if you
absolutely must wear loose-fitting white
clothing which will reflect light and heat
those of you and your officers all in stores
run to your assigned shelters from to your
assigned shelters run for the nearest
shelter but rather close to the world of
building as possible motorist stop your
car get out of your cars immediately at
get out of that car it's dangerous of the tree
while you're running keep close to the buildings
but now suppose the enemy succeeded in sneaking
past our warning system although this is highly
improbable let's assume that the bomb
was delivered without our being alert
when you leave that light forget all about
shelters and preparation just don't look at that
light cover your elbow like this you have just
three seconds oh you're going to use that chance
what you have just seen is the worst that could
happen but remembering this like Sunday saved
your life however there is one other possibility
as we all know by now the bomb is most effective
when dropped from the air but it can also be
carried and exploded those of us who either
work or live near important harbour installations
must consider the possibility of a water first
the characteristic water column run into the
nearest building because within a few seconds
the water that rose skyward with the explosion
will be coming back down in the form of heavy rain
and law that rain will be dangerously radioactive
keep to the center of the building in order to get
as much material and distance between yourself
as that radioactive water keep away from windows
and exterior wall then stay where you are even
then act only as directed by the authorities
well there you have it the bomb will obstruct
the mothers would I perish but most of us those
who will have taken the necessary precautions
will be safe although there will be much left
to do because such an explosion will have left
certain areas dangerously radioactive much can
be done but most of the work will fall on the
shoulders of civilian defense groups disaster
squads and Red Cross units they will be there to
help rule will instruct you to bury contaminated
clothing not to burn it since smoke is a carrier
of radioactive particles they will show you how
your course grease cutting salt when properly used
will either reduce or remove radioactivity from
your body they will tell you to listen attentively
to your radio for important instructions
and they will help those of us who will
not be in a condition to help ourselves
fares will indeed be a noble duty meanwhile
your duty will be to support these groups
and to help organize them it neatly in so
doing you will not be giving something and
getting nothing in return you will be giving
to protect yourself your home and your function
in learning to defend yourself and your
family you are shaping the survival of
your way of life of your heritage in
your future and in that future there
shall come a time when the atomic force
will be used to give us all a better life